this is Jon Snow
he's king in the north
hey everybody they finally did it so we
got to talk about episode three careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get everything I
do a weekly Game of Thrones giveaway so
let's just get into it there's so much
stuff in the battle surprisingly we're
almost non-event so it was more about
the coming together of people's like you
see Daenerys extending an olive branch
to Jon Snow in the form of the dragon
glass and you literally see Samwell
shake Joris hand because I guess the
show has completely cured him I don't
think they're trying to say this Samwell
might get greyscale he seems a hundred
percent cured people trusting one
another but the title of the episode the
Queen's justice was all about final
justice so Cersei gets her justice gets
her gold from the Tyrells Daenerys is
pursuing what she feels like is justice
for the things that have been done to
her her birthright do you know the
things that I've endured which was kind
of funny because they kept not telling
you the things that have happened to Jon
Snow like they only tease you with the
idea that he's come back from the dead
but let's do top 10 and book
references so there were a lot of things
that they referenced from previous
episodes like when Tyrion and Jon came
together let's start with that number 10
Jon Snow and Davos landing on the
beaches of Dragonstone so the waves are
crashing they want to make it feel as
inhospitable as possible which is why I
love the look on all the DOS Rocky's
faces when they were up in Jon Snow's
grill like yeah just try something dude
see what happens let me know if you
laughed with all those references the
Tyrion and Jon fourth spat back at each
other
picked up a few scars along the way just
referencing Tyrion getting part of his
nose chopped off during the Battle of
Blackwater Tyrion referencing being on
the other side of that battle from sir
Davos the bastard of Winterfell
the dwarf of Casterly Rock how did a
bastard become Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch
then become king of the north how did it
Worf and a lannister become hand of the
Queen to Daenerys Targaryen one of the
dragons swoops by them in John sees it
for the first time he had the same look
on his face is when he saw the night
king for the first time
eyes wide John the floor screaming
silently oh my god in all the while you
just have all these quippy one-liners
from Tyrion you never really get used to
it but what I really liked about this
scene though is the way they filmed it
through that winding path so you get the
idea for why they spent
so much time on this staircase when it's
outdoors so it's really well lit so
everything looks that much more
beautiful even though the interior the
throne room is really beautiful too but
you also get this really awesome motion
as they're pushing the camera up the
staircase stark men do not fare well
when they travel south which is a
reference to the fact that every stark
male that has traveled south has been
ended since Robert's rebellion they
also named dropped the Mad King burning
his grandfather in his uncle alive twice
just as with previous episodes they
continued to reference the events of
Robert's rebellion they double down on a
lot of that in the episode because you
go through it again when Jon Snow is
meeting with Daenerys but before we get
to that there was that moment with
Melisandre and Varys which was basically
her just reminding him that they're all
going to die in this war for the dawn
even though Varys is mostly thinking
about the war in the south most of them
like as we saw in the episode have no
idea what's going on with the army of
the Dead which is a little frustrating
but the look on varus's face when
Melisandre told him that is so funny
there been a couple weird things about
bears this season in that he used to
seem like he had one up on everyone else
he was always the one that had the plan
behind the plan behind the plan but now
all of a sudden people are telling him
things that he looks like he's learning
for the first time oh my god you mean
we're all going you mean there's a
night King and White Walkers
so I'll understand if you're a little
dissatisfied with varus's character this
season so far
but number nine Jon Snow finally meets
Daenerys they have this hilarious
introduction from mists and I and then
Davos is just like yeah this is Jon Snow
he's king in the north he's a bastard
that's about it but of all the
fanfiction that's been written about
this moment the first time that they
meet I feel like they were relatively
truthful to the situation Daenerys is
hell-bent on taking the Iron Throne she
doesn't know anything about the war for
the dawn
so her reaction to that I felt like was
pretty natural like you're telling me
that this is mystery thing in the north
that I've never seen and I need to take
my army up there and forget about the
thing that I've been planning to do for
the last six seasons hell no but then
they slowly extend the olive branch but
I feel like it's really hard for the
show to win in a situation like this
because you don't really know what
George are Martin was going to do with this scene and no matter what you do people
are going to cry fanfiction fanservice so I
feel like the way it went
was actually pretty middle-of-the-road
it could have been way worse but it was
really all about getting them and framed
together so like you filmed them really
far apart then slowly she starts
stepping forward and then eventually the
camera perspective switches and you see
her step into frame with him for the
first time so that was what this whole
moment was about just getting them in
frame together and then surprise you
know Daenerys being completely
overconfident I don't need your help
just as Varys comes running in looking
out of breath to tell her that yeah she
definitely needs some help because she
just lost most of her fleet so number
eight they fished Theon out and they
call him a coward wait well everybody
is gone but you survived how did you
survive if you didn't run away coward
and you get that glorious warriors
welcome reverse walk of shame from Euron the sand snakes marching behind them
everybody throwing stuff at them as
they're cheering here on on he rolls up
to Cersei on the Iron Throne and she
just looks so excited like oh my god
it's Christmas Lena Headey has the best
faces like she's so subtle with it this
balance of excitement and rage on her
face as you're on just continues to
taunt Jaime which was probably one of
the funniest moments of the episode and
she just goes on and on laying it on so
thick how do you think your sister likes
it can you give me some advice does she
like the finger in the bum and you could
just see Jaime slowly blowing his stack
so you kind of see how they're setting
the stage for Jaime to break with Cersei
like he's not super into it when they
spend the night together then later in
the episode the Queen of thorns starts
beating him in the face with a - she's a
monster she's terrible she'll ruin you
he still hasn't quite got to that point
so the mistake that Jaime realized that
was in the episode description was
actually something that was a reference
to Robb Stark which I'll talk about in a
second but was anyone else surprised by
how restrained Cersei was in the black
cells with the sand snakes I actually
thought that she was going to be even
more vicious because of what she did to
the shame none you have a zombie
Mountain there she's referencing Oberyn
Martell --zz death hilarious and is
losing it and then you realized that she
sort of turns her attention to tying
your daughter's very beautiful like my
daughter you probably love her the most
like I love my daughter than most so
she's just going to force her to watch her
slowly go out from the same poison that
they poison Marcella
which seems very terrible but I actually
expected the show to do something a
little more graphic I would say that
bran might help her out just because he
has a soft spot for tying in particular
but he's all the way down in Highgarden
so we'll see how long it takes that
poison to work its effects on her but
number seven Cersei just like a boss is
doing whatever she wants she openly
flaunts that she's sleeping with Jaime
to the help and then dominates Thai
CONUS Torres
telling him that she's not the underdog
that she thinks he is so you kind of
spot their strategic mention of
Highgarden they're the next richest
people in the kingdom and they're your
enemies right now so you cut to the end
of the episode as they're loading the
gold up oh yeah just like Cersei said a
Lannister will always pay their debts
so now it seems like the iron bank is
going to continue to fund the Lannisters
war efforts while Daenerys has lost half
of her army and that doesn't even
include the special balista the Qyburn
is making to take down the dragons so
Cersei is seeming like a pretty big
badass right up until the end of the
episode when the queen of thorns just
snatches that ride away from Jaime tell
her I want her to know it was me
but number six Jon Snow and Daenerys
finally coming together them standing
together much closer and frame this is
the closest they've ever been and you
see how they're slowly pushing them
together like okay you can have the
dragon glass which i think is worthless
right now but it's secretly super
valuable to you we'll see how long it
takes for Daenerys to take her forces
north but there was this big speech that
Tyrion gave Jon that was actually
probably one of the better speeches in
the episode about how he needs to give
Daenerys something to believe in it also
at the same time Davos had that remark
earlier where he said the men of the
north believed in Jon Snow that's why
they follow him so at some point this
season
Jon Snow is going to have to make
Daenerys believe in him whether or not
she actually believes in the White
Walkers it makes it a much more personal
thing than coming together like imagine
us getting to a moment where Daenerys
says something like I don't really
believe in all this craziness that
you're talking about north of the wall
but I believe in you like I care about
you so think about where they are right
now in how much distance they have to
cover emotionally before they believe in
each other in that way a lot of great
subtle references and winks at Jon Snow
secretly being a Targaryen these
the dragons they're named for my
brother's rhaegal and Viserion they're
dead now your brothers are also dead too
so they sort of bond over their dead
brothers such a great image of him being
in frame with Daenerys and the Dragons
at the same time but number five not so
much a but just a quick look at how
Sansa is doing being an administrator
Winterfell so like she understands that
there have a really long winter coming
they need a lot more grain than they
have right now she understands what the
cold is going to do to the armor so she
knows how to plan ahead and she gets
that crazy speech from Littlefinger
about how she should be paranoid and
fight battles all over the place in her
mind all the time then you will never be
surprised just as number four surprise
surprise bran rolls up super zen as she
starts losing it I love brains reaction
- hello Sansa just super calm like it's
no big deal
he's creepily serene as they sit in the
godswood and he tries to explain to her
what the war for the dawn is how he's
the three-eyed Raven he understands
everything by accurately describing her
wedding night just making her freaked
out a little bit and it kind of seems
like everybody who got told something
that shattered their reality Daenerys
learning about the White Walkers Sansa
learning about the three-eyed Raven they
both had this maester ebro's reaction
where they didn't outright say that the
people telling them that were lying like
you're lying this is all bullcrap but at
the same time tried to discount it like
this sounds ridiculous but if you're
being so insistent about it and you
won't shut up then maybe you're speaking
some truth so it all comes back to proof
like Jon Snow when he's talking to tear
and how do I prove to people that we
need to focus on the threat of the White
Walkers just keep that in the back of
your mind they're eventually going to
have to literally prove it to people but
number three this episode brought to you
by overconfidence
Daenerys wants to go after your on with
her three dragons in that sit what more
do I need we're invincible nobody could
ever defeat us me that she's ready to
get the rug pulled out from under her as
you go to Casterly Rock in it's almost
anon battle like literally was over in
minutes and I did love the way that
tyrion referenced creating the sewer
system which is actually something right
out of the books but the back door was
literally something that he concocted so
that he could smuggle whores in when he
was older a friend of mine told me give
me ten good
and Island pregnant the bitch that's
actually a line right from Braun meaning
that we were proud again and ready to
see him which we did during the
Highgarden scene but we didn't get any
speaking lines he's just sitting there
right next to Jamie so it was a pretty
good reveal though when grey worm
realizes that something's wrong there
should be more people where are all the
Lannisters as you turn around and see
you're on destroying the rest of their
ships while you jump to Highgarden so
number two was the big high guard in
battle which also was kind of not a big
battle like you see them roll up with
all those Lannister soldiers and then
boom you just cut to the end of the
battle Jaime walking through Highgarden
with all these dead Tyrell soldiers
amount you see them packing the gold up
but really the best part of this was
number one of course the way the queen
of thorns goes out when she's talking to
Jamie so once she tries to talk a little
bit of sense to him even tries to get a
last confession out of him I won't live
to tell any of the secrets that you give
to me and she notices that he's wearing
widow's wail man he was terrible I
laughed so hard when she made fun of
Joffrey and then as Jamie is trying to
be really civil and she takes the poison
immediately and tells him the reality of
how Joffrey died it was just so
beautiful the look on Jamie's face is he
starts to lose it just a little bit but
behind that you see some of the seeds of
doubt that she's sown in him Cersei is
terrible she's a plague you will regret
your role in spreading it just as much
as I have but diana rigg was a great
actress I'm sorry to see her go now's as
good a time as any to end the
character they really want to take
Daenerys ha's small council from her so
she needs more help which is only going to
push her a closer together with Jon Snow
she will need the north very soon but
she still has the dragons she still has
the Dothraki in most of the unsullied
you may have spotted that Robb Stark
comment that Jaime made remember how he
was captured by the Starks during the
war of the five kings because of a
mistake that he made so when the episode
description was talking about Jaime
realising his past mistakes and
correcting them this was the thing
giving up the lesser target Casterly
Rock in favor of the more valuable one
Highgarden so I think a lot of us saw
that and we thought that it might
reference something about a mistake with
Cersei but it seems like that hasn't
quite happened yet but we're slowly
getting there sir she's going to have to be
a little more terrible before Jaime
completely leaves her but let me know in
the comments
what was your favorite part of the
episode Jon Snow meeting with Daenerys
all the references to Robert's rebellion
your ancestor Torrhen Stark bent the
knee to mine Aegon the conquerer even if
they brush over it really quickly it is
a lot of fun to hear them reference
stuff like that but what'll happen next
is is I'll post my Rick and Morty Episode 2
video then I'll post my Game
of Thrones episode 4 trailer and just
like normal Q&A video on Tuesday so
leave all your questions in the comments
and congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Lord bird would please
private message me so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here to learn
all about Jon Snow and dragon bonding
and you can click here for all my other
Game of Thrones videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight!